Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 16th episode!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
For Ruffians that are maybe tuning in for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face,
and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Never quite get it, huh?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new morning!
What type of morning?
A brand new... FUWAMOCO morning.
Yes!
A brand new FUWAMOCO morning!
Well, Ruffians.
Guess what?
There's another Ruffian who's seen Pero.
Yeah, this time... Where?
Where, Moco-chan?
He's in the kitchen!
The kitchen?
It looks like this Ruffian was putting lots of love into making pon-de-rings.
At least, attempting a very good attempt at making pon-de-rings.
I feel like this must be one of the bravest, the most brave Ruffians ever.
The bravest, the most brave.
In case you didn't understand bravest.
Ruffians, you know, it's probably best...
It may be a bit tempting, but you know, don't try to make pon-de-rings at home, okay?
Not unless you have some very strong fire resistance magic.
Yeah, it can be a bit perilous.
This is why Mister Donut is obviously the best.
Because you don't need to make them if you can buy them.
Pon-de-rings, you know, they seem easy to make in theory,
Actually, they're really tricky and a bit dangerous to try to make.
Please don't burn down your house trying to make them.
But I guess you know, maybe if you see Pero there, then it's okay.
We don't dislike Pero that much.
I don't know if we can say that we like him, but we don't dislike him that much.
Yeah, we wouldn't want him to burn to death.
Yeah, we definitely know it speaking from experience.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, hopefully you enjoyed them.
And maybe without Pero swallowing any between blanks or something.
And no fire.
No danger.
No danger, no burns.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Please, Ruffians, let us know if you see Pero around, okay?
Remember to use the hashtag FWMCMORNING if you see her.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Enjoy the yummies.
Ah, pon-de-ring sounds good right now, right?
Ah, right!
A good way to start the morning, right?
Yeah!
Is it?
What's wrong?
Is it that kind of time, Moco-chan?
Time for what?
I think it's time for that.
Ruffians!
There's been a misunderstanding.
Something you know that Moco-chan needs to kind of clear up, I think.
Me?
Yeah, you, Moco-chan.
You know... There's something on my mind.
On Moco-chan's mind.
It should be on your mind too, Moco-chan.
Is it on my mind?
Yeah.
What is in my mind?
About, you know, a dear album member.
So...
I saw that there were some Ruffians were concerned about how Moco-chan talked to Nerissa during a recent collab in Pico Park.
Yeah, Moco-chan, you said that you were going to clean Nerissa up because she was dirty.
Moco-chan, what do you have to say about this?
No reaction?
I don't know.
Was I wrong?
It's not wrong.
Is it really a misunderstanding?
Ruffians, what do you think?
It's bad.
It's not good.
I did nothing wrong, right?
The whistle... The whistle's not dirty.
What?
You don't... You don't actually think the whistle's dirty, do you, Ruffians?
Mococo is right!
Yeah.
No!
No, Moco-chan, you... No.
I'm correct.
No.
Yeah.
No!
I'm gonna purify her!
Purify the demon of sound!
Get rid of the nasty demon that's inside of her!
Moco-chan, you know what demons do?
I think Mococo could cure her of her dirtiness!
Yeah!
I'm here to help you, Nerissa!
Morning deshita.
Now Moco-chan, you're referring to yourself as Mococo.
Third person.
If I'm gonna clean her, then yes.
Watch out, Nerissa.
Moco-chan took your duty.
You're welcome!
Was that an apology at all, Moco-chan?
If it wasn't a misunderstanding.
Was it?
Sorry, Nerissa.
Wow!
There's actually been something else on our minds.
Maybe something we wanted to confess a bit.
Ruffians.
You know, this time, we have something we'd like to confess about a senpai in particular.
We all know she's very, very cool.
We have a lot of very cool senpai.
We do, we do.
But recently when we think of this senpai, we even get a bit teary because she's just that cool!
Oh, maybe it's just you.
I would never get teary.
Moco-chan's just saying that.
Ruffians, can you guess?
Can you guess?
I think she's definitely gonna think we're weird for this.
Oh!
I see it!
There's a lot of Senpai.
It's Calli-senpai!
Moco-chan, thank you for the drawing.
You're welcome.
It's very good.
Exactly the same.
Yeah, you know, Calli-senpai's super busy, right?
You know, she has her new EP, Jigoku 6, that just came out, and has been on a bunch of TV shows and music TV shows recently.
But despite her busy schedule, she still makes time for us and Advent, too.
You know, she responds to our messages even though we're really, we're pretty sure she's in the middle of really important meetings.
And you know, we're pretty sure.
Pretty sure.
And when we message her, you know, say crazy things like this and that.
Just crazy things, you know.
She's really sweet in response.
And she stands up for others and for what she feels is right.
Yeah, yeah.
We feel really lucky to have a senpai like her, you know.
That's really, really cool.
That's cool.
Yeah.
And to be...
To be completely honest, it's not like we've been talking a bunch together through DMs because FUWAMOCO, you know, we have a hard time getting the courage from it, right?
But this is still how we feel inside.
It's tough, you know?
And you know what too?
With FUWAMOCO, we were having a bit of a rough day the other day.
Calli-senpai, she said that she lent us a copy of
Her game that we were having a really hard time getting.
Well, not her game, but our game, she has.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, and that meant so much to us.
It's just, it's just maybe like a little thing.
Yeah, she didn't need to.
Right?
But it was very nice.
You know, we're kind of thinking that, Ruffians, do you know the rules of Versailles?
Do you know the legendary rules of Versailles?
I feel like Calli-senpai is a bit like Oscar.
Yeah.
You know?
That's our thought.
Yeah.
She looks pretty similar the way I do her.
But you know Calli-senpai's very cool.
Very, very cool.
Wanting to put herself in danger to protect those important.
You know?
Just like Oscar!
In danger.
Yeah.
That's our senpai.
Danger.
Dangerous.
Like, giving a game.
Very dangerous.
BAU BAU!
That's what we wanted to confess.
Well, Ruffians.
We also heard that it's a new time of year.
It's that time of year.
It's back to school!
Back to school season.
We really wanted to give a big BAU BAU to any Ruffians who are returning back to school to continue their studies.
We're sure it's really rough on it.
New class, new faces, new strict teachers, and worst of all, mountains of homework and texts to read.
But Ruffians, you can do it!
Yeah!
Hang in there!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we've done a lot of training as Demon Guard Dogs.
And you know, it was really rough.
Really rough.
Yeah, we still always have more training to do, but... You know, Ruffians, we take you on, but we found something more important to protect right now.
Right!
Right.
Protect you.
Yeah.
I think we've done enough training.
You may be a little bit surprised.
We are pretty good at it.
Yeah, we did learn that stuff.
Yeah, very studious.
You know, we never made any excuses like, teacher the dog ate our homework!
Yeah, yeah.
And we never, you know, Moco-chan never switched spots and did my test or something.
You know?
Yeah, we're good students.
Even math.
I cried a lot while I was doing math.
But yeah, math.
And even though it was really hard, it wasn't good.
It felt, you know, kind of just like prison.
Just like we were in the cell.
It makes us feel a bit sick.
Just thinking about it.
Not great.
So, we really wanted to give a big support of BAU BAU to all the Ruffians doing their best to improve themselves and learn as much as they can!
Ruffians!
You can do it!
BAU BAU!
Get on the school bus!
Up to the school bus!
It's time to go to school!
BAU BAU!
Good luck!
Going to school!
They're on the bus now.
They're going.
Ruffians, you know what?
I think
It's another special FUWAMOCO Morning because we have some very special FUWAMOCO Morning Jingles!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
A week ago, we asked Ruffians to come up with their very best jingles so we could all have a special jingle that we can love lots and lots for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Once again, we really want to say a big thank you to every Ruffian for the jingles that they made just for FUWAMOCO Morning.
Each and every one has filled us with so much passion and individuality.
Moco-chan, shall we take a listen?
Is it okay?
Okay.
But Ruffians, remember you have to be like this, okay?
You have to really get into it.
Got it?
Listen very closely, okay?
Get ready to dance a bit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Who's this first jingle from?
This one is a jingle from... Bo... Ed!
Let's listen!
De-den!
It's so cute!
They said they used an instrument called a Kuika.
I've never heard of it.
I know, right?
It's so cute and mysterious.
It has a puppy vibe to it, right?
Yeah, I feel like it has a puppy sort of feel.
Not Donkey Kong.
Donkey Kong?
I don't know.
FUWAMOCO's gonna come and get you!
We're gonna put a smile on your face!
I like it.
You know, we're definitely up to something again this morning.
It's silly.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have a jingle from Ugokubo.
Ugokubo-san.
Let's listen!
It has a bit of a futuristic feel to it.
But it's really cute and it has a refreshing feel.
It feels like carbonated water.
For me, I feel like it reminds me a bit of when you just finish installing and starting up a visual novel for the first time and you take a look at the game menu.
You see all the heroines and there's the bright blue sky.
Next, we have a jingle from Tiana!
Let's listen!
Moco-chan, apparently this jingle is done in a genuine PC-98 format!
I like it!
Amazing!
Impressive!
I get too many good feelings.
It hits you in the bones.
A blanket that I've had for many, many, many thousands of years.
I don't think we talked about this before, but FUWAMOCO, we really, really love the PC-98.
It's one of our dreams to actually have a working PC-90 and be able to play classic visual novels on it.
Someday!
Someday.
It's a bone blanket, yes.
Right, the vibe is so good.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
That was really cool.
Well, this next submission is from Genji!
Let's take a listen.
This is a jingle played on the shamisen.
Ruffians, do you know what the shamisen is?
I wonder.
It might be a lot of Ruffians' first time with a shamisen.
A shamisen is a Japanese lute that's played by plucking three different strings with a...
A thing.
A thing called a bachi.
Yeah, it's really really cool.
They're so good at it too.
I think it must be really difficult to learn how to play the shamisen.
Especially if you're a Ruffian that's outside of Japan maybe.
A lot of Ruffians know about it.
They wrote a paper on it.
Wow, this is really impressive too.
I like the really like, there's like a happy, a happy like traditional feeling from it.
It's funny because it feels also healing but different from the bone blanket.
Yeah, I want to put on a kimono now after listening to it.
Thank you Genji-mama!
And our last single for today.
This one is from Kendo!
Kendo!
Let's take a quick, a quick listen.
Hi!
You're so cute!
You're happiness!
BAU BAU!
It reminds me kinda like a...
When you just start a really colorful co-op game, you know maybe it has like pixel graphics?
Sort of similar but different from Cookie and Cream.
So cute!
And I really like the use of our voices and the little ting at the end too.
And the bonflowers!
Thank you!
Thank you for the BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your jingles.
And thank you for letting us share them today with you!
We hope you enjoyed these few ones that we were able to showcase today.
And we hope that you look forward to the big reveal that's waiting for us on Friday.
It's only two sleeps away, right, Moco-chan?
Yes.
Thank you, Ruffians!
They're so good.
Ruffians are just very, very impressive.
What can I say?
Are you surprised, Moco-chan?
No, I'm not surprised, but I'm just very impressed.
But, Ruffians, on the topic of being impressed, I wanted to say something!
Is it okay if I say something?
It doesn't matter because I'm gonna say it anyways!
You know, today, it's the middle of the week!
And you know, recently, it's been sort of rough.
So, it's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And that means you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo.
Yo!
Ruffian!
It's Wednesday!
And maybe even Thursday!
Congratulations!
You thought the other day would take you down, didn't you?
Huh?
But guess what?
It didn't!
And that's because you're super duper strong!
You're amazing!
You're doing it!
Rain or shine, you continue to go.
And that is something that you need to recognize.
Got it?
Got it!
You can do it!
We can all do it together!
And after this FUWAMOCO Morning, you're gonna go out there and you're gonna show the world just how awesome you are!
Let's take all the silly things in stride and continue to be in control of our own world, okay?
Got it?
Cuz remember, I believe in you!
You can do it!
Ganbatte ne!
That was a good Pup Talk, Moco-chan.
You got this, Ruffians!
You can do it!
Moco-chan, shall we go to our regular corners?
Doggie of the Day deshita.
Okay, but who's our Doggie of the Day today?
It's Juju!
Look at this BAU-tiful smile!
Actually, I feel like this is very impressive.
Can you see those, Moco-chan?
All those healthy white teeth there.
Just like Moco-chan.
Dogs' teeth are really important to their health, right?
Just like Ruffians.
You brush your teeth, right, Ruffians?
It's already FUWAMOCO Morning.
You brush your teeth, right?
Go!
Grab your tooth brush!
You brush your teeth, right!
You know what you can do while FUWAMOCO Morning is on, too?
Juju.
Juju's a German Shepherd.
Kind of like, uh...
You know, German Shepherds kinda similar.
I don't think we have as much whiskers.
Ah, no.
Juju has wonderful whiskers.
But, I think German Shepherds, they like guarding and protecting things, right?
I'm sure Juju's really good at protecting smiles, you know?
So cute.
We're glad that Juju's still lovely.
A happy friend.
Do we have whiskers?
Just use your eyes.
Use your brain.
How does Juju bau bau?
I feel like through the teeth, you know, like... Yeah, you know, I think Juju...
Has a very good sense of humor.
You can see through the sparkly smile, sparkly eyes, a bit shadowy there, but I'm sure they're sparkly.
Strong gommas, yeah.
And you do have some very cute ears.
You can't quite see here, but gravity.
Ravity.
No, no, gravity!
No gravity!
Gravity!
They're very cute.
Oh, Juju!
Keep doing your best to protect your Ruffian smile, okay?
That's all the memory to smile just as big as Juju!
And next, for today, I went on a walk with a Ruffian.
Oh, this Ruffian is active!
Very active.
They went for a hike.
Dangerous.
And what's even better, I think Moco-chan
They made a friend along the way, too!
Is it a squirrel?
A chipmunk?
A tiny friend?
A rodent?
Whatever it is, I want to point.
You know, it kind of looks like one of the rodents in the cartoons.
Risu-senpai?
I don't think Risu-senpai is quite that small.
She's much cuter, she's much cuter.
But you know, I think they probably got really close to you, right?
Either that or you're really good at photography.
Really good friends.
National Geographic.
But yes, you know Ruffians, it's very important not to feed the wildlife, you know, no matter how much we might want to.
And look for it.
Look for it!
Look for it to.
We can't have snacks.
It's for their sake.
We eat our snacks.
They eat their snacks.
It could be fun, you have to dodge them.
I mean, get ready to dodge.
I prefer that in my video games, not in real life.
It's the fun part of hiking, okay?
You never know what's gonna happen.
Make some friends, dodge some rocks.
Exactly!
Ruffians make sure you go on lots of walks, okay?
Falling rocks.
Rocks and rocks.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Question of the Day.
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
It's already September, and it's the season for School Trip!
Whenever it comes to this time, I always recall the days of school trips back in my high school.
Do you have similar experiences when you were students?
I'd like to hear from you.
Thank you for your question!
Ah, well, FUWAMOCO, we have never really been on a shugaku-ryoku like they do in Japan, you know?
It sounds fun.
Right?
Sometimes there'd be like little trips to like a museum where we'd learn about the great Demon Guard Dogs of the past.
But... I don't know.
It's nice being out, but it's not really that fun.
It wasn't that fun.
You know, they make you do homework after that.
It's blaaaah.
It'd be fun if I just learned and didn't have to do work.
Right?
But, you know, it looks really fun in anime.
You know, they go to Hokkaido for sugaku ryoko.
Yeah!
They have a bunch of yummy food, and fun, and great sights.
And at the end of the busy day, everyone all sleeps in the same room together.
Like a sleepover party, right?
Is that really a trip or is it just a vacation?
I feel like it's kind of a vacation.
A vacation?
I don't know, I kind of feel... A vacation with friends.
I feel a little bit envious, you know, when we see Shugaku Ryokan anime.
You know, it's like, it's a multiple
Day trip without parents, right?
Yeah, it'd be fun.
I mean, museums are fun, but I like it when we have to... We can just enjoy and learn like that instead of have to be focused on the homework and getting information for that.
No, no pressure.
Just learning is good.
But considering, you know, shugaku ryoko usually doesn't... The teachers come along, right?
But there's no parents.
I feel like that would've been something we would've never been allowed to do, right?
Aww.
But, you know, even though our youth spent in the classroom may be over now, I think your youth only ends when you decide it has.
So, you know, Ruffians, let's all continue our burning youth all together!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today.
Remember though, we're still looking constantly, every day.
For more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day, for your walks, and of course more questions too!
We wanted to say, you know, we are always keeping an eye on the hashtag, but if you want to retweet your submissions, tweet them again.
Because you think maybe they might have been missed or it's been a little while and you still haven't been on FUWAMOCO Morning.
Please, please do, okay?
Also, you know, I think maybe some Ruffians, they only have one doggy of a day.
I would hope that their doggy is a doggy of every day.
Yeah, but you know you're not gonna be switching out your dogs.
So, I was gonna say...
And for our next stream, what do we have up next?
We have...
Our album!
Album!
We're gonna be making our debut in the hololive Minecraft server.
And for us, it's Minecraft debut.
Yeah.
We're really, really nervous.
Yes.
Yeah.
We've never played Minecraft.
We've watched Minecraft, but I don't know what's going on.
Yeah.
We're just like, oh, this is cool, but I'm lost.
They're not lost.
I don't know what they're doing.
There's a lot of sounds, but yeah.
And you know we were having a bunch of issues today.
So we tried to test it before FUWAMOCO Morning did it, but... We ran into Mikocchi-senpai, and Okayu-senpai, and Aki-senpai!
And you know what?
I didn't even know how to type or move around or anything.
So we just sort of panicked a bit.
Googling how to type in Minecraft!
How to jump in Minecraft!
We didn't get that far.
How do we bow in Minecraft?
But it was fun though!
But very overwhelming.
Thank you Mikochi-senpai for all the takoyaki!
Moco-chan shared one with me.
I promised to share.
Just one.
More.
But you know, because of it, I think we're looking forward to Minecraft even more now, right?
It was fun, wasn't it?
But the debut is just about to start today.
Tonight.
Please look forward to as much as we are, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And!
Our schedule!
Look at the schedule.
Wow, we still have a lot of exciting things happening this week.
But!
On Friday, we have a Japanese lesson with all of Abyss going right on up.
Teacher!
FUWAMOCO Teacher!
We're going to be teaching from the very basics up until having a regular conversation with all of you in Japanese.
We're really looking forward to it.
We've never spoken in Japanese and had a conversation with all of you before.
Ruffians!
We wanted to ask though, is there anything in particular that you want us to teach them?
Do you have any ideas, Ruffians?
Bad words.
We have to use good words with our senpai, okay?
But Ruffians, you don't have to try to think right now.
Let us know with the hashtag, this time, hashtag helpFWMC.
F-W-M-O-C-O.
And that way, you know, we might be able to include it in our lesson plan, right?
Because we're teachers, we need to have a lesson plan.
Preparation.
Yeah, it's good.
You can't think right on the spot, right?
That's okay.
But the sooner you can think of it and tweet about it, that would be appreciated.
Lesson plan has to get written pretty quickly.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
It's time!
BAU BAU!
Hayai.
Wave!
BAU BAU!
Ophiel!
Sea Jacky!
BAU BAU!
Serena!
Pikomaru!
BAU BAU!
Eric!
The Slam!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!